alors j'ai une liste de fournitures pour
une rentrée en classe de sixième on va
commencer par une grande surface tout à
fait classique on y va c'est parti alors
on va commencer par où la 1re attendait
il faut déjà comprendre la liste en fait
un petit peu attention parce qu'il ya
des choses un peu bizarre il ya des
chiffres cache et là par exemple ici
dans le coin et puis il ya aussi des
choses pas très claires comme brouillon
cahier gros carreaux avec tables sais
pas ce que c'est on va voir c'est bon
ce qui me manque encore enfant une voix
pas normalement pas c'est bon on a tous
passent à la caisse
bonjour voilà donc tout est bon j'en ai
eu pour 78 euros 40
on va maintenant aller voir dans une
papeterie indépendante en milieu rural
ce que ça donne bonjour monsieur qu'ils
ont pu pour me font et que vous pouvez
m'aider
bien sûr je donne ma liste oui au tce
merci d'accord voilà donc cette fois ci
j'ai absolument rien à faire c'est pas à
moi de bouger entre les rayons on
s'occupe de moi donc c'est parfait
voilà tout y est monsieur qui selon
trouver les fameux cahiers de brouillon
injectables oui tout à fait ce sont ces
cahiers la la table en fait c'est la
table de multiplication pour les enfants
d'accord comment voyez vous m'éclairer
parce que c'était donc ça des cahiers de
brouillon avec table
voilà bien merci beaucoup ça fait comme
ils ont pris alors ça fra 81 euros 96
-10% 73 euros 75
s'il vous plaît bonne journée aussi
beaucoup au revoir monsieur merci bidon
de la journée j'en ai eu pour 78 euros
40 au supermarché contre 81 euros fier
libraires mais avec sa réduction de 10%
ont passé à 73 euros 75
les prix sont donc sensiblement les
mêmes à ceci près que chez le libraire
pas de files d'attentes pas de temps
perdu
c'est lui même qui m'a fait mes achats
vous n'aurez donc pas besoin d'attendre
la fouille du mois de septembre pour
vous ruer dans les grandes surfaces mais
vous pourrez commander vos articles
manquants au libraire et vous les
donnera à la rentrée